[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Merrill Hodge had the opportunity to
work with Merrell at the mothership for
many years always had great respect for
the homework that he did it's not about
hot takes it's about getting it right
former NFL running back who I believe
I don't know how many players have
played for Chuck Knoll and Bill Cowher
but uh has is that right you played
for both those coaches
yes yeah two legends um which I find
myself fortunate to have done that
because Chuck Knowles the greatest man
I've ever met and then what Bill coward
did in the position that he was in I
don't know of another human being that
could have done what Bill did and it was
both guys were different but both guys
great leaders uh your video clip went
viral the last couple of weeks with you
with Skip Bayless when you were arguing
Johnny Manziel but I want to know what
research you did like what did you know
about Johnny Manziel that maybe others
didn't because skip was all in and a lot
of people were on Johnny Manziel you
were all out on Johnny Manziel why
well you know you know how it was at the
mothership day you know they they came
over to me and asked me if I would come
over and do
um first take with um
um with Skip and he said he's talked to
some coaches
as soon as I heard Dad I'm like well
that's that's like really low hanging
fruit right there because that means he
doesn't know anything he's talked to a
bunch of coaches and who those coaches
are were quite honestly Irrelevant this
is actually the truth foundationally
with every organization that's getting
ready for tomorrow
the foundation of every player that's
being looked at I don't care what the
organization is we're talking about
they've studied them on tape extensively
um they went back all of their games to
study them on tape which I had done that
with Johnny now the one thing that was
disturbing is he never played in
structure and then people always say it
was so exciting and I'm like you know
that's not a skill set
um and you don't draft somebody because
they're exciting but if you understand
structure and how he's supposed to
execute plays he hardly ever did it and
then I had a good friend actually was my
quarterback coach at LSU he's the office
coordinator of Steve craigdar for the
time they tried to recruit him and then
I heard a lot of stories about how they
recruited and how he was as a person in
high school how he played in high school
he was reckless in high school but he
was exciting he never played with
structure um Mike um Mike Sherman was
the um office coordinator there um and
he had run a system there that was
similar to systems you might see in the
NFL
um but he redshirted and his response at
the to that question is what did you
learn was probably the most telling
aspect of everything he's like well I
was red shirt and I didn't learn
anything and just when I heard that I
was like okay that just tells you who he
is they only watched him play and if you
took all that action that other stuff
away Dad I'm just telling you from
people get caught up in where the kid
plays versus where he's going to play
and in our league this what makes Tom
Brady the greatest quarterback in the
history of our league he executes the
play he plays in structure and he does
like if you're gonna make Tom Brady
throw a hitch 12 times in a row he will
throw a hitch 12 times in a row you know
how many quarterbacks will say you know
what Tyler's throwing a hitch I'm gonna
throw the Dig but the Dig is not there
Tom Brady is second of five and the
other team is second and ten there's
your difference
all right how many quarterbacks have a
first round grade
this draft
I got one um an fcj Stroud and he is
unique from this perspective let's talk
about this these are the two things that
have to be woven together if you do not
have these two things your ability to
win consistently in the National
Football League are going to be very
hard you got to process decision making
okay the processing and decision making
aspect and accuracy has to be that
combination like if you don't have that
you've got a big problem one of those
teams is going to run one of those two
things if you don't have it runs you out
of our league okay he does have it um
Bryce young has that as well but then is
when you got to go a little deeper into
those two things
the luxury Ohio state has Alabama has
half the time they're just better than
everybody else you know and so what's
hard to do but you have to do it and you
have to find enough evidence to see how
they function in it is how will they
play in the environment in the NFL that
the NFL is going to create and majority
of all throws in the NFL are from a
dirty collapsed pocket there's traffic
uh they don't have the luxury of being
better than everybody else half the
season okay so how do they function
within that when you look at that
category now the decision making and
accuracy aspect and arm strength come
into play CJ Stroud is strong he is
dynamic I mean his ability to throw
accurate wise will attack he can attack
every inch of the field every inch of
the field you take Bryce young into that
pocket collapsing environment he doesn't
have a big enough arm so he's Limited in
where he's going to be able to throw
and he's not the same quarterback he
can't make those throws and that's going
to be a a big consistency in the
National Football League where he's
going to have to play that he doesn't
play like CJ Stroud does I still love
him I still think he does a great job I
think he could be a good quarterback
he's just not I wouldn't put a first
round pick on him because that
expectation is you're going to be elite
you're going to take us to a
championship and you have to have this
as part of your evaluation he is fragile
he is not very big and he's already
displayed that in the two years at
Alabama last two years the year where
they were dominant in one Heisman trophy
they're a dominant team he was awesome
now when they weren't quite the team
that they were the previous year people
got the hitting people got around him
more and he didn't play the entire
season he got hurt because you're
hitting now when they hit him and when I
say when they hit him here's what
happens in the NFL sometimes you're like
well I can we can get our corner there
but I don't know if he can get a
quarterback down okay in this case your
kicker gets there then they wipe him off
the map I mean they may charge people
for murder when they hit him when he got
hit just in college I gave him a 10 for
toughness because there's so many times
I'm like man he ain't getting up from
that yeah and that has to be an ultimate
you have to take that you have to have
that discussion because in our league
he's going to get hit
um he is not physically he's very
fragile
um and you have to be okay with him not
playing
um a few games every year you have to be
you have to accept that that could
happen and then with his limited ability
to throw from a dirty pocket NFL
environment
CJ strong doesn't have those things
um and I wouldn't put that on my coach
if I have the choice I'm going to take
the guy that doesn't put those
limitations on me and CJ Stroud does not
do that I think he is unique
um he is powerful he is strong his
Dynamic he's accurate and he will fret
every inch of the field and he is truly
special from that perspective talking to
Meryl Hodge the former ESPN analyst he's
an author inspirational speaker let's go
the the other quarterbacks here will
Levis appears to be rising up a little
bit
why yeah
these actually they are actually the
bowl of the same category let's go back
to the two things you got to have
accuracy and decision making okay both
are Highly Questionable okay now
decision making we can sit there and
argue you know and somebody could sell
me on well you know here's why I made
this decision you can clean that up and
he's going to be better you're never
changing accuracy and here's the biggest
mistake that has made in the history of
our game with every organization you
think you can fix something you cannot
fix you cannot fix actually and I go I
go from I've coached kids from 8 to 38.
actually coaching the football is
probably the best thing ever happened to
me because I see the genetic makeup of a
kid I see a kid who's accurate you know
what 10 years later he's still accurate
I see a kid who's not accurate he's
still not accurate even though he worked
on it and you can work on it you can
make your actually a little better but
at the end of the day when you're in the
heat of fire you're going to be who you
are and that is not very accurate both
guys when I say erratic I mean will
Levis I mean he's made some throws from
a hitch I mean short intermediate and
vertical too okay there's not just one
category where he's not good at I mean
he makes some throws where even the
receiver just turns around goes like
what was that like consistently you know
and um I went back and looked at his
last two years and he was better his a
year ago than he was this last year and
actually everybody blamed his I said
always offensive line was bad I'll tell
you this I'd be pissed if I was an
offensive lineman because he sacked
himself more and got himself into
trouble more by having awful pocket
awareness which was another layer of
concern I'm like that's an instinctive
thing you know that's something that
okay go back to who's the greatest
quarterback Tom Brady what made him so
great and what did they attack him for
why did they knock John Gruden tells
this story we we downgraded Tom Brady
because of his 40. the dumbest
evaluation in the history of football
because it's irrelevant it's irrelevant
what is relevant is how he moves within
that spacing and Brady never ran it's
magical Brady never ran 40 yards at one
point in his career do you have her do
you have Anthony Richardson in there
with the same kind of description with
will love us
yes okay his decision making his
accuracy and just it's it's it's below
average at very best from clean pocket
dirty pocket Mobility I mean moving
right moving left every platform it is
consistent he's inaccurate you're not
changing that and that and that will get
him exposed to the NFL eventually it
just it's unacceptable and it'll drive
you out early it happens all of the time
but well I'll fix it there's coaches now
listen this sometimes the GM is making
this call the coach is saying don't do
this I can't fix that what you're gonna
do it that's why I hired you I'd like
that happens all the time too I like
Hendon hooker but he is coming off
surgery and he's 25. is he a first round
will he be a first round pick
no he could no no no a guy who was
accurate a guy who processes things well
um and I believe is um devoured because
of that that injury that the injury has
to be you know considered in the whole
thing will it be able to play when it
but the two things I just talked about
he does have that you know I put tape on
him and I was like you know I don't know
about this kid you know that's one thing
I don't know about any of them so take
tells me I'm only going about what the
tape tells you I I when I talked about
five of those games of him I'm like oh
my gosh like the more he gets
flat-footed at times which you know it
gets him in trouble and that's when he
becomes inaccurate but you can work on
that and fix that okay that's a that's a
technique that he didn't get better at
um but his accuracy and his processing
of the system they had it was a very
sophisticated system but that's all you
can go on he processed that well he
threw big he made Big Time throws in Big
Time situations under a lot of pressure
um and I liked it from that perspective
I think you can build from guy if
somebody gets in the second round
they're gonna get a steal they'll get a
steal would not be surprised if he
doesn't go in the first later uh since
you were a former running back Bijan
Robinson uh you know from what I my
source says he might be the best player
in the draft but he won't be taken as
the best player because he's a running
back right you know Dan I was in his
path I watched him on tape okay he is
gifted now here's what makes him gifted
okay and here's the difference between
college and NFL most people don't
realize that the fields are different
the NFL field is different than the
college field and as soon as I say that
everybody's like what do you mean that's
not the difference yeah it is the hash
marks in college are wider
hash marks of college are narrow so in
the NFL we play in the middle and
college will play on the perimeter and
so when you're watching a kid in college
you got to look at how does he play in
the middle you know how can he create
how can he make a dirty play into a good
play meaning there's traffic the hole's
there but it's not really a lot clean
this guy will clean up a lot of bad
plays because he's laterally and
vertically Dynamic his feet and his
fluidity is rare it is special you can't
teach that he has explosiveness he has
power he has speed he'll block he can
catch and so he is going to when he
comes into this league his transitioning
will be very easy for him when I was at
his pro day and you know I was talking
to him and here's what I fell in love
with him we were talking about you know
asking who's your favorite player and he
said uh Barry Sanders and I said well I
mean that's not that's not a bad guy to
have as your best player I said how much
do you know about Walter Payton because
when I played in Chicago
Walter Payton was retired at the time I
learned a lot about Walter Payton aside
from him being a great football player
but we would talk about the game and how
he played and the mindset in which he
had
and he talked about something I actually
heard as a 15 year old kid he talked
about his mindset of wanting it every
day and what that did for him is it it
forced him and it challenged him every
day to get everything out of his
god-given ability so I shared that with
him and I'm like you need to look on up
about Walter Payton he was listening to
you know some of these kids are like
yeah whatever you know get out of my
face and and if he came over to talk to
me too by the way he started the
conversation but then he listened
intently so I tell him about this Walter
Payton thing and I said here's what your
job is to get everything out of your
god-given ability that's what you have
to do if you want to be greatness league
if you'll do that every day you need to
study things on Walter Payton you need
to try to be create that mindset Like
Walter Payton and you could put a gold
jacket on one day and he's like can I
get your number you know could you share
more stuff with me and just just that
just how he was as a human being and a
kid I'd heard about that too but to see
it and and experience it with him and
share that with him and he would take
that on and embrace that just whoever
gets him is going to get just an
absolute star I mean
I think
it I thought it was a dramatic pause but
I think he froze up there
yeah we'll take a break uh Merrill if
you can hear me thanks for joining us uh
the former NFL running back that's great
great stuff you know what there's
there's no vagueness to what he's saying
about these draft picks here and uh
author inspirational speaker Merrill
Hodge